This now brings us to the end of this advanced landscape tutorial series.
I'd just like to quickly recap what we went over when we first started with our initial project setup,
and that was setting up a new project based off of the third person template.
We then enabled some plugins, edited our INI files, imported some textures and some static meshes,
and then we moved on to creating our landscape material.
Now remember, our landscape material allowed us to have the various textures displayed based off the slope of the landscape
instead of having to go in and define them or paint them manually by hand.
We then took a look at how we could utilize displacement inside of our landscape materials
to give our landscape materials a more defined and realistic look.
We also looked at how we can adjust our material for our landscape so that in the distance,
the tiling artifacts are not as apparent as they would be.
We then looked at how we could implement landscape grass and some interesting ways to control its placement on the landscape.
We also took a look at how we can utilize landscape physical materials that will allow us to define
different physical properties of different surfaces that are used within our landscape.
Next, we looked at how we could edit our level using things such as gizmo brushes
and even utilizing hand painted brushes, as well as how to utilize level instanced actors,
level packed actors, landscape patches, and finally finishing with how to utilize and adjust HLODs on our landscape.
I hope you enjoyed this video tutorial series as much as I enjoyed having you, and I will see you next time.